POWERFUL HOLD HE HAD OVER ME.
>> SO YOU SAID THAT HE DRUGGED
AND ASSAULTED YOU, YOU SAID,
MULTIPLE TIMES.
>> YES.
>> YOU WERE A TEENAGER.
AND ASPIRING ACTRESS.
WHAT DO YOU BELIEVE HAPPENED?
>> WELL, THERE WERE SEVERAL
OCCASIONS THAT I WOULD, I WOKE
UP -- OUT OF A VERY CONFUSED
STATE.
NOT IN MY CLOTHES.
THERE WAS AN OCCASION AT THIS
BROWN STONE IN NEW YORK CITY
WHERE I HAD GONE FOR DINNER.
AND HAD ONE GLASS OF WINE WITH
DINNER.
THERE WERE STAFFERS THERE.
THE HOST WAS MINGLING WITH
PEOPLE.
BEFORE I KNEW IT I WAS -- WITH
MY HEAD OVER THE TOILET,
THROWING UP.
AND HE WAS HOLD MIGHT HAIR OUT
OF MY FACE.
WHILE I THREW UP.
I WAS IN A WHITE T-SHIRT AND MY
PANTIES.
AND HE WAS LOOMING OVER ME IN A
WHITE ROBE.
>> SO, YOU WERE AT HIS HOUSE AT
A DINNER PARTY.
WERE YOU THERE TO BE WITH HIM?
>> I WAS THERE ALONE.
AND HE HAD BEEN MENTORING ME AND
GROOMING ME.
I'M FROM DENVER, COLORADO.
WHEN I WAS 17.
MY AGENT INTRODUCED ME TO HIM TO
GROOM ME.
MENTOR ME.
GET ME READY FOR SHOW BUSINESS.
PART OF THAT WAS BRINGING ME TO
NEW YORK CITY.
>> DID HE MAKE ADVANCES TOWARD
YOU, WHEN YOU WEREN'T, YOU
BELIEVED YOU WERE DRUGGED, WHEN
YOU WEREN'T DRUGGED DID HE MAKE
ADVANCES TOWARDS YOU?
>> IT WAS A VERY -- CONTROLLING
AND MANIPULATIVE ENVIRONMENT.
IT WAS VERY -- VERY CONTROLLED.
VERY ISOLATED.
AND THERE WERE TWISTED THINGS.
THERE WERE TELLTALE SIGNS.
>> NOTHING OVERT?
>> THERE WAS SOMETHING PRETTY
OVERT IN RENO, NEVADA.
BUT BY THAT TIME I WAS VERY MUCH
UNDER CONTROL AND UNDER HIS
THUMB.
I DON'T RECALL THAT THERE WAS,
THERE WERE DRUGS.
>> SO AFTER THE INITIAL TIME,
YOU SPENT, YOU SAID, RENO,
NEVADA.
YOU ALSO WANT TO I BELIEVE
ATLANTIC CITY.
YOU PUT YOURSELF IN A POSSESSION
TO BE CLOSE TO HIM AGAIN.
WAS THAT NAIVETE, YOUTH, WHY
WOULD YOU DO THAT?
>> I WOULD SAY IT IS SO MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS.
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT GO
THROUGH SO MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS.
I WAS YOUNG.
I WAS IN NEW YORK CITY.
HE AND MY AGENT WERE SUBSIDIZING
MY HOUSING, ACTING CLASSES.
MY JOB WAS TO FOCUS ON ACTING.
DO WHAT I WAS TOLD.
STAY ON THE STRAIGHT AND NARROW.
WHEN THINGS STARTED TO HAPPEN
WITH HIM, I COULDN'T GO TO MY
AGENT.
I WAS TERRIFIED OF HER.
AND I WAS TERRIFIED OF HIM.
IF I STARTED TO ASK QUESTIONS OR
I WOULD GET, THE CONFUSION FROM
THE DRUGS.
AND I WOULD BE ASKING QUESTIONS.
HE WOULD SAY WELL YOU WERE
DRUNK.
AND, I WOULD SAY, WELL I CAN'T,
I CAN'T -- I WASN'T DRUNK.
BUT I CAN'T LET MY AGENT KNOW I
WAS IN THAT POSITION.
SHE'LL.
I AM SUPPOSED TO BE WORKING HARD
IN NEW YORK.
>> HOW DO YOU THINK HE DRUGGED
YOU?
ANY IDEA?
>> I NEVER SAW ANY DRUGS.
BUT I WOULD WAKE UP COMPLETELY
CONFUSED, HALF DRESSED.
AND KNOWING THAT MY BODY HAD
BEEN TOUCHED WITHOUT MY
PERMISSION.
>>- YOU HAVE STRUGGLED OVER THE
YEARS.
TO HAVE YOUR ALLEGATIONS TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
WASN'T UNTIL A COMEDIAN TALKED
IT.
SOME TIME LATER, 30 YEARS LATER.
>> ACTUALLY NO, I HAVE BEEN
SPEAKING OUT PUBLICLY AND TRYING
TO HAVE THE STORY BELIEVED AND
HEARD SINCE 2004.
>> DO YOU THINK IT HAS BEEN
TAKEN SERIOUSLY?
>> IT IS STARTING TO.
I AM REALLY GLAD NOW IT IS A
RELIEF TO KNOW THAT THE CRITICAL
MASSES ARE STARTING TO FINALLY
PAY ATEPAY ATTENTION.
>> YOU HAVE NEVER TAKEN LEGAL
ACTION NO?
>> I DIDN'T, NO.
AND I DIDN'T.
WHY DIDN'T I?
WELL, I TRIED.
I TOLD MY AGENT ONE TIME.
SHE DID NOT BELIEVE ME.
I, A FRIEND OF MINE IN '89 TOOK
ME TO AN ATTORNEY.
HE LAUGHED ME OUT OF THE OFFICE.
AT THAT POINT, NOBODY WOULD
BELIEVE ME.
HE WAS DR. HUXTABLE.
EVERYBODY'S DAD.
I LOVED HIM.
I WANTED HIM TO BE MY DAD.
NOBODY BELIEVED ME.
I WAS SO BROKEN DOWN AT THAT
POINT.
AND HAD GONE THROUGH SO MUCH, OF
HAVING THIS, MY MIND, COMPLETELY
MANIPULATED.
I JUST, WHEN I GOT, KICKED DOWN
IN NEW YORK CITY.
PUT ME BACK TO DENVER WITH THE
CLOTHES ON MY BACK.
THINGS GOT LOCKED IN THE
APARTMENT.
I HAD TO SUE TO GET MY THINGS
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, DON.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OVER THE YEAR, COSBY THROUGH
HIS ATTORNEYS REPEATEDLY DENIED
SEXUALLY ASSAULTING ANYONE.
ACCORDING TO "THE WASHINGTON
POST," A REPRESENTATIVE FOR BILL
COSBY DID NOT RETURN MULTIPLE
CALLS AND E-MAILS FROM
"WASHINGTON POST" STAFF.
FOR "WASHINGTON POST" STAFF,
COMMENTS ON BARBARA'S OP-ED TO.
DAY WE SPOKE TO A